sur notre site Internet et chacun sera
attentif au respect du temps de parole
et du respect des uns et des autres je
vais donner immédiatement la parole à
notre collègue Cyril pelvat pour le
groupe les républicain vous avez la
parole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mes chers collègues ce 8 juin
l'horreur absolue a frappé la paisible
ville d'Annecy sur les berges du lac un
assaillant a attaqué à l'arme blanche
quatre très jeunes enfants de 22 à 36
mois deux on vit leur pronostics vitaux
engagés et deux adultes ont été
également gravement blessés cet acte est
de lors de l'indicible on protège un
enfant on le console on l'éduque mais
jamais au grand jamais on ne le poignard
dans sa poussette collectivement le
coeur des Français s'est brisé pour les
victimes et leurs parents mais aussi
pour les passants traumatisés je le
réitère notre entière et soutien car si
l'inquiétude concernant l'état de santé
des blessés s'est dissipés le chemin de
la guérison temps physique que psychique
sera encore long je tiens également à
rendre hommage aux préfets à nos forces
de l'ordre et de sécurité civile aux
soignants et auréoro du quotidien comme
on rit pour leur bravoure leur
formidable mobilisation a sans aucun
doute permis d'éviter un bilan encore
plus lourd j'ai pu voir leur choc et
l'aurait froid face à la cruauté d'une
telle attaque mais cela ne les a pas
empêché d'être admirable je souhaite
aussi témoigner ma reconnaissance aux
élus locaux pour le réactivité en
particulier au maire d'Annecy François
Astorg et lucifié mon soutien face aux
attaques indignes dont il fait l'objet
enfin Madame la première ministre nous
vous sommes reconnaissants ainsi qu'aux
président de la République et au
ministre de l'intérieur de vous être
rendu rapidement sur place pour
signifier le soutien de l'ensemble de la
nation
si leur est aujourd'hui au recueillement
et s'il nous faut éviter les polémiques
plusieurs zones d'ombre demeure je ne
doute pas que l'enquête en cours viendra
nous éclairer sur le parcours de la
saillant mais migratoire comme
cicatrique mais les premiers éléments
qui nous sont parvenus interroges il
apparaît en particulier que les délais
de traitement de sa demande d'asile ont
été particulièrement longs alors qu'elle
était manifestement et recevable le
système Eurodac permettait pourtant de
vérifier qu'il avait déjà obtenu cette
huile réfugiée en Suède comment
expliquer vous donc la décision de refus
ne lui a été signifié que six mois après
le dépôt de sa demande en outre l'achat
des droits fondamentaux de l'UE prévoit
qu'il est possible d'accorder la liberté
de circulation ressentissant de pays
tiers résidant sur le territoire d'un
membre il s'agit bien d'une faculté
laissée à discrétion des états et non
pas d'une obligation je souhaiterais
donc savoir si vous comptez restreindre
ce doigt qui lui permettait de séjourner
en France son visa pour une durée de
trois mois je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cyril pelvat alors vous l'avez
rappelé jeudi dernier dans la matinée un
homme a attaqué de très jeunes enfants
dans un parc à Annecy il n'y a rien de
plus lâche de plus choquant de plus
monstrueux que de s'en prendre à
l'innocence de s'en prendre à de jeunes
enfants
4 enfants et deux adultes ont été
grièvement blessés dans cette attaque je
me suis immédiatement rendu sur place
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur et le
président lui-même a été aux côtés des
familles en soutien à tous les
intervenants dès le lendemain au nom du
gouvernement et comme vous monsieur
sénateur je veux dire mes pensées à
toutes les victimes adresser ma
solidarité à leur famille et à leurs
proches et dire mon soutien aux
habitants et aux familles d'Annecy
profondément choquées par cette attaque
je veux aussi remercier et rendre
hommage avec vous aux forces de l'ordre
qui sont intervenues extrêmement
rapidement ainsi qu'au secours aux
soignants aux citoyens dont l'action a
permis de sauver les victimes et
d'éviter l'irréparable
monsieur le sénateur pelva comme vous et
comme tous les Français je souhaite que
la lumière soit faite sur les
circonstances exactes de cet effroyable
attaque une enquête est en cours elle
permettra d'éclairer les faits les
parcours et les motivations de l'auteur
en attendant les conclusions de cet
enquête leur est-elle la dignité l'heure
est au recueillement leur est au soutien
des victimes de leur famille et des
habitants d'Annecy et je peux vous
assurer que d'un autre côté le
gouvernement reste mobilisé plus que
jamais pour protéger les Français je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Loïc Hervé pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le président
il faisait beau ce jeudi matin au bord
du lac sur le paquet à Annecy tout à
coup dans le square au pied du pont des
amours qui enjambe le canal du vase un
assaillant armé d'un couteau à l'avenir
poignarder plusieurs petits enfants
jusque dans leur poussette avant de s'en
prendre à des personnes âgées nous
devons au premier témoin d'avoir ralenti
l'agresseur puis à la chaîne
exceptionnelle des forces de l'ordre
secouristes et soignants d'être
intervenus avec une rapidité
exceptionnelle qui a permis de sauver la
vie de toutes les victimes notre
reconnaissance aujourd'hui à leur égard
est immense
depuis cet événement tragique la ville
et toute la Haute-Savoie sont sous le
choc la venue des plus hautes autorités
de l'État dont la vôtre le jour même
madame la Première ministre et le
rassemblement citoyen de dimanche ont
été des occasions de témoigner notre
unité et aussi notre solidarité avec les
familles
et si quelque polémiques à ses veines
ont été balayées et c'est tant mieux des
questions lourdes restent posées et
attendent des réponses courageuses
madame la Première ministre celle-ci
sont à mes yeux de deux ordres
l'application des règles du droit
d'asile et la psychiatrie
pachengen fixe des règles européennes de
liberté de circulation il n'existe pas
en soi de liberté d'établissement
l'auteur des faits semblerait avoir
choisi de résider dans les rues d'Annecy
depuis 7 mois deuxièmement l'état de la
psychiatrie hospitalière en Haute-Savoie
est catastrophique des services ont été
fermés à l'hôpital de Thonon pour être
transféré à l'hôpital de La
Roche-sur-Foron ou un tiers des lits
sont fermés par manque de personnel dans
ces conditions comment imaginer une
politique de prévention digne de ce nom
comment aller vers les populations de
son domicile fixe souvent étrangers de
plus en plus nombreux qui sont dans des
situations de véritables marginalité
madame la Première ministre en parallèle
avec l'enquête judiciaire en cours
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles sont
les décisions préventives que le
gouvernement entend prendre pour qu'un
tel d'Aram ne se reproduise jamais
madame la Première ministre pour
répondre à notre collègue merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le Président Loïc
Hervé alors vous avez raison de le dire
le drame survenu à Annecy jeudi dernier
est un choc terrible pour tous nos
concitoyens à l'heure actuelle les 6
blessés dont 4 jeunes enfants sont hors
de danger j'ai à nouveau une pensée pour
eux pour leur famille et leurs proches
et nous le devons cette bonne issue
finalement en tout cas d'avoir évité le
pire à l'action des forces de l'ordre
des secours des soignants et des
citoyens à nouveau avec vous je veux
leur rendre hommage monsieur le sénateur
aujourd'hui l'enquête se poursuit elle
permettra de tirer les conclusions sur
le profil l'étape psychiatrique le
parcours et les intentions de la
saillant et je veux le redire nous avons
naturellement interrogé tous les
services de renseignement des autres
pays européens nous avons naturellement
interrogé les autorités judiciaires et
aucun signalement n'avait été connu
s'agissant de cette agresseur et aucun
signalement psychiatrique n'avait été
fait préalablement en parallèle et
indépendamment de l'enquête et du drame
notre mobilisation continue avec le
gouvernement avec tous les élus qui
comme vous monsieur le sénateur veulent
agir pour la sécurité de nos concitoyens
et veulent veiller au respect de nos
frontières et peut-être pour répondre à
la question précédente je pense en effet
que ce genre de demande d'asile et
maintenant une personne qui a déjà le
statut de réfugiés dans un autre État
membre doit pouvoir être traité plus
rapidement et nous allons également
examiner ce point au-delà des démarches
importantes et des avancées que nous
portons au niveau européen et qui ont
notamment pu se traduire lors du dernier
conseil des ministres de l'intérieur par
la définition d'une procédure de demande
d'asile obligatoire aux frontières de
l'Europe qui je pense répond à notre
attente et répond à l'attente de
beaucoup des tambres Européens je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Fabien
gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste sous
un la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le 30 juin prochain une nouvelle étape
va être franchie dans la libéralisation
du secteur de l'énergie avec la
suppression des tarifs réglementés du
gaz et la fin du bouclier tarifaire dès
le lendemain
2,6 millions de foyers vont devoir
passer d'un contrat fixe et régulé à une
offre de marché c'est une folie dans la
période de crise énergétique vous avez
une vision
erronée des cours du gaz sur le marché
mondial car la stabilité que nous
observons depuis le début de l'année
2023 n'est qu'une accalmie les prix
restent hauts et risquent d'augmenter à
nouveau des cet hiver dans un contexte
de concurrence mondial pour la livraison
du gascatari et du généal américain et
de reprise économiques de l'industrie
chinoise pourtant souvenez-vous la
concurrence devait faire baisser les
prix le résultat rien que pour le gaz
c'est plus de 90% sur les tarifs en une
décennies et depuis la crise énergétique
c'est un bon de plus de 50%. plus
personne ne croit en votre fable car
pour les usagers nos entreprises et nos
collectivités c'est leur raquette au
profit des acteurs alternatifs et des
traders qui gonflent leur dividendes
grâce au marché européenne l'énergie
dans ce contexte notre groupe a déposé
une proposition de loi pour prolonger
les tarifs réglementés du vent du gaz
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
prolonger les tarifs réglementés ou
allez-vous laisser 2,6 millions de
foyers être livrés au marché et
s'enfoncer dans la précarité énergétique
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie ils avaient la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Fabien gay c'est
pas une femme c'est une réalité que je
vais vous raconter une histoire qui fait
que depuis un peu plus d'un an les
ménages français sont protégés contre la
hausse des prix du gaz et le TRV n'a
rien à voir dans l'affaire la réalité
c'est que TRV ou pas si le gouvernement
n'avait pas mis en place un bouclier
tarifaire les hausses des tarifs aurait
été exceptionnel je le répète TRV ou pas
vous savez très bien ce qui se passe au
1er juillet monsieur le sénateur le TRV
en est terminé conformément à une loi
voté par les deux Chambres de
l'assemblée et promulgués en 2019 elle
va se traduire par en fait aucun
changement pour la plupart des 2
millions et quelques ménages que vous
mentionnez puisque par défaut ils
passeront sur le tarif dit passerelle
d'engie et pour les autres qui auront
décidé de changer de fournisseur
j'imagine que s'ils le font c'est parce
qu'il considé bien que le nouveau
fournisseur est meilleur marché ils ont
peut-être même des baisses de prix au
total vous le voyez bien on est en train
de protéger les ménages français par le
bouclier tarifaire le prix du gaz vous
le savez aujourd'hui il est revenu assez
plus bas qu'ils prévalait même avant la
crise et avant la guerre en Ukraine et
ça il faut le reconnaître aujourd'hui
que le marché européen nous y aide
évidemment le monsieur européen vous
savez il faut il faut le changer nous le
faisons en profondeur notamment sur la
fixation des prix de l'électricité mais
aujourd'hui ne faites pas peur à des
ménages qui je le répète au 1er juillet
nous verrons rien si ce n'est peut-être
pour certains d'entre eux une baisse de
tarif merci
monsieur gay
alors si monsieur le Président jusqu'à
quand monsieur le ministre nous allons
respecter des règles européennes que
plus personne ne respecte mise à part
nous les Portugais les Espagnols ont
obtenu une dérogation les Allemands
viennent aujourd'hui même d'annoncer un
plan de 50 milliards d'euros pour
subventionner et notamment sur le prix
du tarif du gaz et nous on respire point
lié à ses règles plus personne ne
respecte et qui mettent à bas nos
collectivités nos entreprises et surtout
les usagers il est urgent de recréer un
grand service public de l'énergie avec
un monopole public et si vous le faites
pas nous le ferons à votre place
[Applaudissements]
la parole est
au président François Patriat pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant de la
parole monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues comment
évoquer les problèmes de l'enfance sont
à mon tour évoqués aussi le drame
terrible arrivé récemment dans plusieurs
villes de notre pays acte ont Dieu acte
monstrueux que nous condamnons tous avec
fermeté et nos pensées avec les vôtres
vont à la fois aux victimes aux familles
aux cités et à leurs proches sans faire
le lien bien évidemment média je
voudrais madame la Première ministre
vous interroger sur le problème de
l'enfance en associant à ma question mon
ami Xavier yakovelli particulièrement
impliqué dans ce domaine vous avez
annoncé il y a quelques jours mais c'est
vrai que c'était occulté par les
événements dramatiques que nous
connaissons vous avez à l'issue du
Conseil national de la refondation
évoqué la création d'un service national
de la petite enfance de façon à assurer
un meilleur accueil pour les enfants en
bas âge de notre pays cela répond en
effet à une un engagement pris à
multiples reprises par le prix dans la
République et que vous avez tenu en
effet aujourd'hui recrutement
insuffisant
disparité régionale
insuffisance et inégalité sociale
importante il est aujourd'hui
indispensable de revaloriser le métier
d'accueil véritable pilier de notre
politique familiale mais aussi véritable
pélier pour abriver un accès équitable à
l'emploi et au travail aujourd'hui donc
c'est une pierre supplémentaire dans la
politique qui mène au Pôle Emploi
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et le
gouvernement tient à le faire avancer ce
fond est doté aujourd'hui d'un
d'un milliard et demi de dollars de
francs un milliard et demi de francs et
sur cinq ans ce qui fait en cumuler un
milliard et demi d'euros pardon
excusez-moi je suis impressionné par la
lourde très bien ce fond ce sont mes
chers collègues et donc de thé d'un
milliard et demi d'euros en projeté sur
cinq ans ce qui fait 5 milliards et demi
et cette et c'est 5000h30 seront ancrés
par l'État et de plus vous avez annoncé
vous avez annoncé madame la bonne la
ministre que ceux en répondant en cela
aux acteurs de terrain ce serait les
communes qui seraient de demain les
autorités organisatrices il y a donc
deux choses qui ont intérêt contre
assemblées aujourd'hui la petite enfance
et d'autre part les communes concernées
pouvez-vous nous donner quelques détails
sur ce service public de l'enfance
Madame le Ministre madame la Première
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président François Patriat
assurer l'accueil de la petite enfance
c'est construire l'avenir de notre pays
et montrer le modèle de société que nous
voulons car on améliorant l'accueil des
jeunes enfants nous répondons à une des
premières préoccupations des parents
nous avançons pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et nous levons un
des freins majeurs à l'emploi depuis 6
ans nous avons avancé mais aujourd'hui
encore les parents vivent trop souvent
un parcours d'obstacles pour obtenir une
place d'accueil de fortes inégalités
sociales persistent et au total le
nombre de places reste insuffisant c'est
pourquoi conformément aux engagements du
Président de la République j'ai annoncé
un plan ambitieux avec le ministre des
Solidarités Jean-Christophe combe pour
lancer un véritable service public de la
petite enfance créée 200 000 places
d'accueil supplémentaires d'ici 2030 et
garantir à tous les parents une réponse
pour enfants notre objectif est d'abord
de permettre une meilleure coordination
entre les acteurs en confortant les mers
dans leur mission en tant qu'autorité
organisatrice de l'offre d'accueil et je
connais l'engagement des mers et je veux
le saluer ainsi le projet de loi pour le
plein emploi qui portera les mesures
législatives correspondantes prévoit que
les offres d'accueil comme les besoins
des parents sont recensés à l'échelle de
la commune il prévoit également que les
grandes communes élaborent des schémas
stratégiques pour définir une
trajectoire de développement de l'offre
adaptée aux besoins des familles et je
sais Monsieur le Président Patriat que
votre groupe y est particulièrement
attentif ensuite nous allons augmenter
considérablement les moyens dédiés à la
petite enfance conformément à ce que
nous avons prévu dans notre trajectoire
budgétaire nous allons investir plus de
5 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
d'ici la fin du quinqu il s'agit
d'accompagner à la fois les
investissements des collectivités mais
aussi comme elles le souhaitent le
fonctionnement pour ces nouvelles places
de crèches nous voulons également
faciliter la vie des parents
œuvrer à l'attractivité des métiers et
améliorer la formation et je veux ici
rendre hommage à tous les professionnels
de la petite enfance enfin nous allons
renforcer la confiance dans le système
d'accueil notamment en renforçant les
dispositifs de contrôle et j'ai confié
la présidente du conseil départemental
du Maine-et-Loire Florence Dabin une
mission pour identifier des solutions
rapides et efficaces pour prévenir la
maltraitance monsieur le Président
Patriat avec le service public de la
petite enfance nous garantissons l'accès
à une solution d'accueil pour tous nous
agissons pour le plein emploi en levant
une barrière au retour au travail nous
ouvrons pour l'égalité des chances et
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
ce sont des objectifs que nous
partageons j'imagine tous ceux que vous
partagez tous sur ces bancs et avec la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs et les
élus nous réussirons je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Isabelle
briquet pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président ma question
à laquelle j'associe ma collègue ma
collègue Marie Arlette Carlotti
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères madame la ministre
alors que la guerre se poursuit en
Ukraine et que les populations civiles
continuent d'y vivre sous les
bombardements incessants nous nous
interrogeons sur la stratégie du
gouvernement en ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement à la nécessaire aux
construction de ce pays amis ces
derniers mois les bombardements russes
ont en effet particulièrement ciblés les
infrastructures civiles le barrage de
kalkhovka est malheureusement le dernier
exemple en date ces bombardements des
organisent le pays a fait affectent le
quotidien de millions d'Ukrainiens à
moins de risques leurs conditions de
résistance et soulève la question de la
reconstruction
si le gouvernement français a apporté un
soutien financier à l'Ukraine il n'a pas
précisé sa stratégie en matière
d'accompagnement des autorités dans le
rétablissement des services essentiels à
la vie quotidienne de la population
quel secteur allons-nous prioriser avec
quels moyens dans quel cadre certains
pays l'Union européenne sont d'ores et
déjà présents pour appuyer pour appuyer
les efforts du gouvernement ukrainien
dont de nombreux secteurs d'activités la
France n'est pas pour l'instant au
rendez-vous pourtant des opérateurs
nationaux notamment privés se sont dit
prêt à s'engager en faveur de ce pays
alliés à condition que la zone rouge
soit au moins partiellement levée cela
rendrait possible leur action dans un
contexte relativement moins incertain
elles sont envisagées et sous quel délai
au-delà nous voudrions également savoir
quel est le mandat donné aux opérateurs
publics comme expertise France ou l'AFD
afin qu'une action concertée soit
réellement possible madame la ministre
la France doit être aujourd'hui et
surtout demain aux côtés du peuple
ukrainien je vous remercie
vous répondre la parole des cartes
madame la ministre de l'Europe des
Affaires étrangères madame Colonna merci
Monsieur présent mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
l'Ukraine ne sera pas vaincu elle se
relèvera et lorsqu'elle aura sûrementé
cette épreuve elle sera unie et
pleinement ancrée dans la famille
européenne c'est notre conviction et
nous y travaillons d'ores et déjà en
complément de l'aide d'urgence imposée
par la guerre que c'était de soi
militaire on en parle souvent aux civils
notamment au moment les plus difficiles
de l'hiver ne vont aider à la résilience
du peuple crinien ou que ce soit
évidemment une aide humanitaire comme
nous l'avons encore montré ces derniers
jours après le sabotage du barrage en
envoyant déjà 10 tonnes de matériel et
nous travaillons d'ores et déjà à
l'après c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons nommé en mars et la France
était le premier pays du G7 à le faire
un envoyé spécial chargé de la
reconstruction il s'agit de d'une
excellente qualité il travaille en lien
avec les Ukrainiens pour identifier
leurs besoins prioritaires et avec les
bailleurs internationaux pour construire
les financements la France met aussi en
place des mesures concrètes pour les
entreprises françaises qui
souhaiteraient s'engager en Ukraine
elles sont nombreuses la conférence qui
s'est tenue le 13 décembre dernier à
Bercy la montre et nous réfléchissons je
peux vous le dire madame la sénatrice
aux règles de sécurité sachant que
l'Ukraine est pour leur un pays en
guerre je participerai enfin le 21 juin
à Londres à une conférence
internationale sur la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine et j'annoncerai notamment de
nouveaux financements pour la
reconstruction des infrastructures
civiles critiques celles dont vous
parlez celles qui sont attaquées jour
après jour par la Russie vous le voyez
madame la sénatrice il n'est pas trop
tôt pour s'occuper de l'après et c'est
ce que nous faisons et nous le faisons
depuis des mois déjà je vous remercie
vous avez quelques secondes si vous
voulez non
la parole est à notre collègue Guylaine
Pantel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 se tiendront du 26 juillet au
11 août et du 28 août 8 septembre 2024
il s'agit d'un rendez-vous très attendu
par nos concitoyens tant ils revaient
une dimension populaire et
multiculturelle le 23 mai dernier vous
avez signé un protocole de sécurité de
la cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux cela
représente au total une mobilisation de
35 000 membres des forces de l'ordre
gendarmes policiers et agent du
ministère des armées auquel s'ajouteront
des agents de sécurité privée pardon et
ceux de la ville de Paris aussi vous
avez annoncé le déploiement de 2800
agents supplémentaires d'ici d'ouverture
des Jeux il ne fait aucun doute que ces
décisions sont le fruit d'une évaluation
détaillée des besoins d'une
manifestation de cet envergure
or monsieur le ministre force de
constater que l'on voit peindre dans nos
territoires ruraux la probabilité d'une
réquisition des agents des services de
sécurité publique qui exercent
quotidiennement dans nos brigades de
gendarmerie et commissariat de police la
conséquence indésirable qui se profile
c'est l'impossibilité en termes
d'effectif d'assurer un appui pour la
protection des événements sociaux
culturels et sportifs dans nos régions
et d'en provoquer l'annulation
en effet bon nombre d'associations n'ont
pas des moyens financiers d'engager des
sociétés de sécurité privées et les
petites communes ne disposent pas de
policiers municipaux
ainsi avant que la flamme olympique ne
gagne Paris plus de 60 départements
devraient être traversés or vous
conviendrez que cela ne servirait à rien
si une partie des Français était privée
d'un été festif en 2024
en conclusion que prévoyez-vous pour
garantir l'équilibre territorial des
effectifs des services de sécurité
publique sur la période des jeux
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
les renforts estivaux seront-ils
maintenus et les psychiques ne vont-ils
pas être déplacés je vous remercie pour
vous répondre la parole est à madame la
secrétaire des tâches chargé de
citoyenneté dans Sonia baquet vous avez
la parole madame la ministre merci
monsieur les sénateurs
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 vous le savez sont un événement
planétaire qui nécessitera une
mobilisation totale et sans précédent de
nos forces de sécurité Gérald Darmanin a
eu l'occasion de le dire devant vous
l'engagement du ministère de l'Intérieur
est des Outre-mer ne pourrait être que
total pour garantir la sécurisation
optimale de l'événement mais aussi pour
garantir et assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens dans les territoires les
forces de sécurité intérieure seront en
première ligne vous l'avez dit chaque
jour près de 35000 à 35000 agents des
forces de sécurité intérieure seront
mobilisés la réserve opérationnelle de
la gendarmerie nationale forte de 31.000
femmes et hommes et les réserves des
écoles de police et de gendarmerie
seront également mobilisées la décision
était prise de suspendre le temps des
jeux la distinction entre zone de
compétences police et gendarmerie cela
permettra une organisation par mission
plus adaptée à la situation l'engagement
des personnels de sécurité privée des
agents des polices municipales et des
militaires des forces armées sera
nécessaire pour parfaire le dispositif
global bien sûr nous pourrons compter
sur l'appui de l'ensemble des techn pas
envie de sécurité de renseignement
autorisés par la loi sur l'ensemble du
territoire national les forces de
sécurité seront mobilisées pour garantir
la sécurité quotidienne des Français le
ministère de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer vous le savez a demandé au
préfet de mettre en œuvre des plans zéro
délinquance vous le voyez madame la
sellatrice tout est fait pour anticiper
et préparer au mieux cet événement
majeur pour la France sans mettre en
difficulté les territoires vous savez
pouvoir compter sur la mobilisation
entière des femmes et des hommes de la
gendarmerie et de la police nationale
nos forces de sécurité seront n'en
doutons pas à la hauteur je vous
remercie
la parole est maintenant au président
Guillaume Gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Première ministre jeudi dernier
l'horreur a frappé Annecy et à étreint
le cœur du pays tout entier cette
personne dont quatre enfants ont été
victime d'une sauvagerie aussi absurde
qu'un compréhensible à toutes les
victimes à leurs parents à leur famille
à leurs proches à la ville d'Annecy
meurtrie à son maire François Astor il y
a la France sidérée les écologistes
apportent tous leurs soutien le pire de
l'humanité côtoie souvent le meilleur
nous admirons l'héroïsme des passants
qui ont tenté de s'interposer celui
d'Henri qui a mis la saillant en fuite
nous saluons le professionnalisme des
forces de l'ordre qui ont interpellé
rapidement l'individu le sang froid de
celles et ceux qui ont prodigué attend
les premiers soins nous remercions les
médecins qui ont travaillé sans relâche
grâce aux bouclier inestimable que
représente nos services publics encore
pire a été évité madame la Première
ministre alors que les vautours avaient
quitté leur nid plus vite qu'à l'heure
que tu mets vous avez avec la droiture
que vous nous connaissons appelé chacun
à la dignité nous saluons ce propos nous
le faisons notre face à l'horreur le
plus grand danger qui guette le corps
social c'est la désunion face à la folie
la colère et la haine émotion
compréhensible s'en est à moi
parfaitement zen la haine néonazi qui
s'est déversée en toute impunité dans
les rues d'Annecy appelle la
condamnation la plus ferme de tous les
républicains la haine raciste qui se
déchaîne contre le maire d'Annecy
appelle le soutien sans faille de toute
la classe politique nous appelons chacun
et chacune à ne pas céder aux sirènes de
la démagogie à ignorer les solutions
toutes faites aussi
inepte qu'un juste la haine la peur et
le rejet de l'autre ne peut protégeront
jamais nos enfants bien au contraire
c'est la justice la bienveillance
l'inclusion la solidarité la prise en
charge de la maladie mentale tout ce qui
lutte contre la misère et l'isolement
tout ce qui renforce la communauté
humaine qui protégera la nation et ses
enfants madame la Première ministre
comment comptez-vous agir pour assurer
la tenue de cette ligne de dignité merci
pour vous répondre la parole de
kebanables la première Mini
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Gontard vous avez rappelé
l'effet et le drame qui a touché à une
si jeudi dernier et profondément marqué
notre communauté nationale qu'il ne soit
permis à nouveau de dire mon soutien aux
victimes ma solidarité envers les
familles les proches et les années siens
qui me soit permis encore car nous ne le
faisons jamais assez de rendre hommage à
la police nationale à la police
municipale au secours aux soignants et
aux citoyens qui ont permis de stopper
rapidement ce drame et de sauver les
victimes alors qu'il est leur jour ne
sont plus en danger monsieur le
Président gantta gantard l'enquête fera
la lumière sur les circonstances
précises de ce qui s'est passé il ne
m'appartient pas d'un anticiper les
conclusions
certains ont tenté de qualifier les
faits et leurs auteurs alors même que
nous ne connaissions pas son identité
que certaines victimes étaient entre la
vie et la mort
façon un tel drame il n'y a pas de place
pour des polémiques politiciennes soyez
sûr monsieur le Président que je
refuserai toujours les accusations
hâtives et les tentatives de
récupération elles ne sont pas dignes du
drame que nous avons traversé alors avec
le ministre de l'intérieur avec les
forces de sécurité intérieure nous
sommes mobilisés nous sommes au travail
pour protéger les Français je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Daniel Chassin pour le grand plus
indépendants République et territoires
monsieur monsieur le Président Madame de
mise la chantée chers collègues le
président de la République veut
renforcer la souveraineté de la France
quand à la production de médicaments
c'est bien il faut aussi améliorer les
conditions de travail des infirmières
libérales je viens de rencontrer en
Corrèze les représentants d'un collectif
de 340 infirmières tous les jours de la
semaine le week-end des jours fériés ces
professionnels passionnés par leur
métier se rendent au domicile des
personnes dépendantes et pour des soins
chroniques pilier du maintien à domicile
elles sont pourtant maltraités au niveau
de leurs revenus l'indemnité forfaitaire
de déplacement est passé 2 euros 30 à
2,50 € en 2011 l'indemnité kilométrique
de 0,35 à 0,50 en 2009 les actes
médicaux infirmiers de 3 euros à 3 euros
15 en 2009 plus rien concernant la
nomenclature des actes le BSI bilan des
soins infirmiers a été sub ais acte de
infirmier de soins il existe trois
forfaits de BSI BSA
BSA pour Charles prise en charge légère
BSB intermédiaire BSC lourdes un exemple
une personne de 93 ans dépendantes mais
non d'un continent est classé BSA il
existe trois passages à domicile matin
toilette lourdes midi les médicaments le
soir pour la toilette l'infirmière
d'apercevoir 36 euros percevés avec les
is aujourd'hui elle ne peut facturer que
le BSA 3 euros 13 euros certains
infirmières sont obligés de refuser des
soins
beaucoup d'actes sont ornement captures
madame lebilis faut conserver les
infirmières et sont les collaboratrices
indispensables des médecins elles sont
les fantassins du maintien à domicile
pourtant elles n'ont bénéficié d'aucune
revalorisation depuis 2011 Comment
allez-vous prendre en compte leur
légitime revendication
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
minute déléguée chargée de
l'organisation territoriale et les
professions de santé madame Firmin le
Bodo merci monsieur le président
mesdames messenatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Chassin
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur de
souligner l'importance et le rôle
primordial des infirmiers infirmières
libéraux dans notre système de santé il
s'agit de la première profession de
santé libérale en France métropolitaine
elle est également la plus présente en
zone rurale et dans les petites
agglomérations François brode et
moi-même nous cessons de le réaffirmer
le gouvernement soutien en application
essentielle des infirmières libérales
auprès des patients à ce titre nous
accordons bien entendu une importance
prioritaire au sujet de leur
rémunération d'une part parce qu'il est
important de reconnaître financièrement
l'étendue des services de santé qu'ils
assurent d'autre part parce que comme
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens ces idées
sont touchés par les tensions sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui parcourt l'ensemble
des secteurs économiques face à cette
situation nous avons souhaité que les
partenaires conventionnels puissent
ouvrir des négociations rapides et
ciblées pour que les idoles bénéficier
d'un rapide soutien à leur activité de
soins ces discussions se sont ouvertes
avec l'assurance maladie les échanges de
la semaine dernière se sont bien
déroulés et devraient nous l'espérons
aboutir rapidement à un accord nous nous
pouvons que nous en féliciter sur le
sujet du BSI je connais également les
débats qui traversent la procès la
profession sur le déploiement des bilans
de soins infirmiers j'ai eu l'occasion
de prendre une tournée avec une
infirmière libérale et nous en avons
échangé largement si les déploiements de
ce B ici étaient décalé je veux vous
assurer sur ce point cette réforme du
mode de financement des actes infirmiers
demeurent pertinentes et nous souhaitons
la poursuivre rapidement il s'agit en
effet d'un outil pertinent et efficace
dont les infirmiers se sont d'ores et
déjà saisi enfin la meilleure
reconnaissance des idées passe aussi par
une meilleure connaissance de leur
compétences et de leur expertise
l'ouverture d'un nouveau champ
d'exercices autonomes en exercice
coordonné pour la prise en charge des
plaies le droit de prescription
d'administration de l'ensemble des
vaccins ou encore l'expérimentation de
la réalisation de certificats de décès
enfin dans le cadre de l'examen de la
PPL valthou le gouvernement soutiendra
l'amendement permettant de créer le
statut d'infirmier référent c'est aussi
ce que nous faisons dans avec
l'ambitieux chantier de refondation du
métier d'infirmier que nous avons ouvert
le 26 mai dernier
madame la ministre d'écouter ses
professionnels elles font un travail
formidable pour le maintien à domicile
la parole est à notre collègue Laurence
Garnier pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à la première ministre madame
la Première ministre dimanche dernier
des délinquants des soulèvements de la
terre ont violé des propriétés privées
détruit des outils de travail
saccagés les cultures des maraîchers
nantais
ils ont arraché des cultures
expérimentales
économe en eau qui avait précisément
pour vocation de préparer la transition
écologique du maraîchage
sur le site et c'est encore plus grave
il y avait des élus de la République
présent en écharpe tricolore aux côtés
de céderlinquants ils sont la honte de
notre République
le 25 mai à Saint-Brevin il défilait la
main sur le cœur contre les violences
d'extrême droite le 11 juin à
Pont-Saint-Martin il soutenait les
violences des écho théoriques d'extrême
gauche madame la Première ministre vous
êtes la garante de l'ordre public et
vous avez les moyens d'agir
les conseils des ministres se succèdent
et la dissolution promise des
soulèvements de la terre n'est toujours
pas prononcé c'est pour quand
vous devez aussi agir à l'encontre des
élus présents et demandez à votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur de les suspendre
de leur fonction comme motorisent le
code général des collectivités
territoriales
l'écologie est en train de devenir le
totem d'immunité d'une extrême gauche
qui appelle de ses vœux la zalisation de
notre pays
madame laminet vous avez cédé à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes ne cédez plus face
au totalitarisme vert
pour vous répondre la parole et
communiste déléguée chargez du renouveau
démocratique pour parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Laurence Garnier merci pour
votre question évidemment
le concept vous faites il est partagé
très largement au-delà d'ailleurs des
clivages politiques quand on veut
militer quand on veut militer pour le
climat on arrache pas des salades on
arrache pas du muguet quand on veut
militer pour la terre on ne harcèle pas
et en humilie pas les agriculteurs qui
nous nourrissent et qui font vivre la
terre et quand on prétend porter une
cause sociale écologique humaniste on
s'en prend pas aux gens encore moins aux
forces de l'ordre on organise pas des
manifestations interdites c'est une
évidence que vous rappelez et Seigneur
pour cela que je peux vous confirmer que
nous le gouvernement à la ferme
intention la première ministre à la
ferme intention de pouvoir présenter en
conseil des ministres le dossier de
dissolution des soulèvements de la terre
le dossier est en cours de constitution
de manière à être absolument impeccable
comme vous pouvez vous pouvez l'imaginer
après vous m'interroger vous interrogez
le gouvernement sur la présence d'élus
il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
clairement il y a quelque chose qui ne
va pas un élu de la République quel que
soit son mandat quel que soit son parti
n'a pas à participer à une manifestation
lorsqu'elle est interdite par la
préfecture c'est la base c'est la base
un élu de la République n'a pas
participé de par sa présence et donc à
cautionner par sa présence des exactions
qui sont réalisées en l'occurrence
contre des agriculteurs tout en
prétendant les défends lorsqu'ils sont
dans leur territoire ou leur
circonscriptions ça aussi c'est la base
madame la sénatrice et nous sommes
pleinement d'accord enfin quand on porte
une écharpe tricolore quand on est
porteur de la confiance de ses
concitoyens quand on est porteur d'un
mandat qu'il soit local ou qu'il soit
national on doit tout simplement être à
la hauteur de la confiance qui nous a
été conféré et la hauteur du drapeau
tricolore que nous arborons je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue que lui
va pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain
monsieur le ministre du Travail
l'Observatoire des inégalités vient de
sortir un dernier rapport et il est
parfaitement documenté et il prouve s'il
le fallait avec des arguments
extrêmement sérieux que la fracture
sociale continue à se creuser dans ce
pays les ouvriers et les employés qui
représentent 20% des Français ne voient
pas leurs conditions de vie s'améliorer
et pire encore ne voient pas des
perspectives d'avenir pour leurs enfants
et ils prennent de plein fouet la
réforme des retraites qui les pénalisera
à eux en premier nous n'y reviendrons
pas nous voyons arriver là-dessus le
projet de loi pleine emploi alors certes
dans ce projet de loi il y était
question nous avions entendu parler de
travail obligatoire pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA cette mesure ne
figure plus dans le projet de loi
d'abord elle était complètement
incongrue et ensuite elle était de toute
façon
impossible à mettre en oeuvre il
n'empêche il n'empêche que nous pensons
très fortement que ce projet de loi
servira à stigmatiser les plus pauvres
d'entre nous ils jettera l'eau propre
une fois de plus sur les plus propres
d'entre nous parce que il est simpliste
de penser que on pourra mettre à
l'emploi des gens qui en sont
aujourd'hui le plus éloignés parce que
ceux qui restent aujourd'hui ou RSA sont
ceux qui sont les plus éloignés de
l'emploi donc monsieur le ministre moi
je vous demande simplement quelle mesure
vous allez prendre dans les mois qui
viennent pour enfin prendre en compte
cette question de la fracture sociale
sans pour autant toujours stigmatiser
les plus pauvres
la parole des communistes du travail du
plein d'emploi et de l'insuffisant
monsieur du stop merci à Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Libin
sur la fracture sociale et sur les
difficultés qui peuvent lui survenir je
crois que une des causes de la fracture
sociale c'est la précarité le maintien
dans la précarité c'est l'exclusion et
le maintien dans l'exclusion lorsque
nous regardons les faits qui sont là
aussi très bien documentés je pense à un
rapport de la Cour des comptes de 2022
que disent que disent rapport au sujet
des allocataires du RSA il dit que en
moyenne 7 ans cette année complète après
une première inscription au RSA 42% des
bénéficiaires sont toujours inscrits au
RSA soit de manière continue soit de
manière récurrente et il dit que
seulement 33% de ces mêmes inscrits on
retrouve un emploi souvent un emploi
d'ailleurs qui ne se caractérise pas par
la stabilité et c'est un euphémisme je
crois que nous avons à agir parce que ce
chiffre 4 4 allocateurs sur 10 qui
s'étend après sont encore RSA ça vient
signer une forme d'échec collectif échec
sur des questions de formation nous y
répondons avec le pics la prendre du
temps mais c'est efficace
échec aussi sur notre capacité à
accompagner lorsque l'on regarde la
création du RMI en 1988 la loi disait
que 20% des fonds devaient être consacré
à l'insertion et 80% à la location
aujourd'hui nous sommes à moins de 10%
pour l'insertion c'est aussi une
explication que faire le gouvernement
c'est investir de manière massive dans
cet accompagnement c'est ce que
préconise le rapport que m'a remis le
haut-commissaire au mois d'avril est-ce
que nous voulons faire c'est réformer
l'accompagnement des allocataires du RSA
le réformé comment d'abord en mettant
des moyens je l'ai dit en ayant un
diagnostic social et professionnel et un
suivi social et professionnel de chacun
aujourd'hui presque un allocataire sur
cinq 17%
n'a ni suivi social ni suivi
professionnel et on élaborant avec eux
en application de la loi non pas de la
nouvelle loi mais la loi de 88 un
contrat d'engagement réciproque
prévoyant des activités d'insertion de
formation d'accompagnement nous ne
parlons pas de bénévolat obligatoire ni
travail gratuit mais d'accompagnement
est-ce que nous y arriverons sur tous
peut-être pas mais le pire ça serait
renoncé ça serait renoncé parce qu'il y
a un million 950 000 foyers qui
aujourd'hui ne vis que du RSA et ça ça
n'est pas une situation acceptable c'est
cela qui nourrit la fracture sociale que
vous dénoncez merci Madame Lubin
monsieur le ministre je partage ce que
vous venez de dire une fois n'est pas
coutume parce que le rapport de la de la
de la de la Cour des comptes et
parfaitement explicite et nous savons
que la dans une dans une mesure assez
importante l'inclusion ne fonctionne pas
mais dans votre projet de loi dont nous
aurons l'occasion de discuter j'ai vu
certaines mesures dont je ne comprends
pas bien l'utilité je n'ai pas vu de
moyen supplémentaires et je crains qu'on
ne confie l'insertion des bénéficiaires
du RSA à des personnes qui ne les
connaissent pas parfaitement qui ne
connaissent pas suffisamment ses publics
la parole est à notre collègue Tabaro
pour le groupe les républicains vous
avez la parole
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires les lois l'homme et
climat-résiliens sont engagés la mise en
place progressive de ZFE l'objectif est
d'éviter 7000 décès par an directement
liés aux oxydes d'azote qui proviennent
majoritairement du transport routier
mais comme vous le savez un grand nombre
de nos concitoyens vivent très mal ces
différentes mesures cette perception est
confirmée par une consultation
sédatoriale ou sur plus de 50 000
réponses 86% sont défavorables ou très
défavorables aux ETF nos concitoyens
voudraient bien mais ne peuvent pas
quelquefois se séparer de leur
automobile faute de moyens pour le faire
ou de transport en commun adapté c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
souhaité après une cinquantaine
d'auditions présentées en rapport
d'information que j'espère réaliste
concret et de bon sens au terme de ce
travail nous vous adressons un certain
nombre de recommandations réponses aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens mais là
parfois très rejet dans le contexte que
nous connaissons de baisse de pouvoir
d'achat aussi Monsieur le Ministre
êtes-vous prêt à renforcer les
dispositifs d'accompagnement pour les
ménages modestes et ce résidant loin des
élèves avec le prêt à taux zéro ou le
leasing social êtes-vous prêt à
synchroniser le développement d'offres
en transport commun et assouplir le
calendrier de restriction de circulation
comme le Sénat le préconise êtes-vous
prêt à rendre ce dispositif plus lisible
et engager une réelle planification de
plus long terme pour éviter d'envoyer 13
millions d'automobiles à la case dans
moins de deux ans êtes-vous prêt tout
simplement à réconcilier qualité de
l'air et acceptabilité sociale si ce
n'est pas le cas monsieur le ministre
j'ai peur que les temps sont sociales
que les gouvernements ont connu avec la
hausse du coût du carburant les
limitations à 80 km/h ou la taxe carbone
ne soit que le hors-d'oeuvre de ce qui
vous attendent demain
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires vous avez
la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur taboro avant toute chose je
suis prêt à vous recevoir avec le
président Longeot pour que vous puissiez
me donner le caractère complet de ce
rapport dont je salue l'existence et la
temporalité j'avais eu l'occasion il y a
quelques semaines ici même de vous dire
que le 10 juillet je crois pas avoir
donné le jour mais qu'au début du mois
de juillet France
urbaine et les élus qui sont d'ores et
déjà concernés par une partie de ces aid
et feux a commencé par le président
moudunk et par la vie présidente de
l'euro métropole de Strasbourg
Anne-Marie Jean vont me remettre un
rapport sur d'après eux tout ce qui ne
va pas tout ce qu'il faut améliorer et
la manière de rendre plus facile plus
acceptable plus soutenable ensemble du
dispositif j'ai lu dans quelques bribes
de presse des idées qui me semblent
pertinentes qui me semblent pouvoir
aller dans le bon sens et j'en profite
peut-être pour amener tout de suite un
ou deux éléments d'apaisement rien dans
la loi rien
ne prévoit pour le gouvernement d'aller
un jour imaginer interdire les critères
de pour les critères 3 il n'y a que les
agglomérations qui seraient en
dépassement de seuil qui serait
concernés le chiffre d'agglomération
susceptible de se retrouver dans cette
situation et à l'heure actuelle de 5 et
la loi prévoit que une partie des 43
agglomérations concernées pourront
bénéficier d'exonération contenu de leur
qualité de l'air et nous sommes sur le
point de publier ces chiffres qui va
concerner de nombreuses agglomérations
plus de 150 000 habitants dans le pays
je vous rejoins sur beaucoup de points
d'abord si nous avions posé la question
française est-ce que vous êtes pour que
on diminue le nombre de décès des
particules fines des dioxydes d'azote ou
de l'espérance de vie 100% des gens
auraient dit oui pour autant c'est pas
parce qu'un objectif est noble que les
moyens qui permettent de
l'atteindre ne doivent pas être regardés
de façon fine vous évoquez y compris
dans votre rapport le fait que la
pollution de l'air ne se limite pas à la
question du transport routier et qu'il
faut qu'on ait une approche globale
notre vision elle est simple protéger la
santé de nos concitoyens faire en sorte
d'avoir une réforme qui soit concrète et
qui assouplisse le dispositif des aides
en préservant l'essentiel mais en
évitant les crispations qui pourraient
être générer par une application aveugle
avec quelques secondes si vous souhaitez
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Marie maison pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
j'ai bien conscience en posant cette
question quel l'intègre pas la totalité
du territoire national
ni qu'elle concerne la totalité des
Français mais que voulez-vous elle
appelle une question une réponse
nationale
elle concerne la ratification par la
France d'un accord européen
portant sur la durée de travail en
télétravail des travailleurs frontaliers
accords qui comme vous le savez
permet ou permettra dès le 1er juillet
prochain avec l'autorisation de
l'employeur de passer de 25% à 49% la
durée de travail télétravail
télétravaillée en maintenant c'est ça
l'avantage le régime de couverture
sociale dans mon département un beau
département celui de la Moselle que je
vous invite à visiter toutes et tous
100 000 plus de 100 000
travailleurs frontaliers passent je
dirais essaie de passer la frontière
avec tant de difficultés puisque toutes
les voies routières autoroutières sont
saturés et les bus et les trains sont
tous bons
et voyez-vous cette
avancée européenne
pour y régler non seulement le volet
social mais aussi le volet
environnemental et améliorer
sensiblement Falla rendre moins pénible
la qualité de vie de ses habitants mais
pour que cette avancée ne soit pas
fictive mais qu'elle devienne réels
encore faut-il que la France comme l'a
fait l'Allemagne et le et la Belgique
ratifie cet accord est simple monsieur
le ministre quand allez-vous ratifier
cet accord et
leur ratifierez-vous merci beaucoup pour
vous répondre la parole est communiste
du travail du Président Monsieur du stop
vous m'interrogez effectivement sur la
signature possible par la France de
l'accord multilatérale consacrée au
télétravail en rappelant l'application
de la loi telle qu'elle est prévue
aujourd'hui puisque en application du
règlement européen dites coordination
des régimes de sécurité sociale
règlement 883 les travailleurs qui
télétravail actuellement plus d'un jour
par semaine dans leur état de résidence
voient leur législation sociale calculer
dans leur état de résidence si il
travaille plus d'un jour et non plus
dans la rue dans les dans l'État
employeur pardonnez-moi depuis la crise
du covid les différents États membres se
sont entendus de manière dérogatoire et
provisoire pour augmenter le nombre de
jours de télétravail possible sans qu'il
y ait bascule dans la législation
sociale de l'État de résidence et avec
maintien dans législation sociale de
l'état où est situé l'employeur cette
période de flexibilité a permis
neutraliser les effets sociaux du
télétravail pour accompagner nos
compatriotes frontaliers face à cette
situation où la crise a amené un délai
plus loin très sensible du télétravail
nous avons voulu tous les attaques
membres travailler pour intégrer plus
durablement ces changements et une
commission administrative pour la
coordination des régimes de sécurité
sociale a été créé et à mise en place
une période de flexibilité jusqu'au 30
juin cette année les États membres de
travail et de ce travail du groupe adoc
est sorti un accord multilatéral qui a
déjà reçu l'agrément d'un certain nombre
d'États membres et d'état frontaliers
nous sommes en train de regarder
aujourd'hui quels sont les conséquences
exactes de cet accord multilatéral vous
l'avez évoqué sous l'angle de la
facilité de vie pour nos compatriotes
transfrontaliers qui pourraient ainsi
travailler à leur domicile plus
facilement il faut aussi que nous
puissions mesurer les effets en termes
de recettes de cotisation sociale
d'externalité sur les bassins d'emploi
de dépenses indemnisation chômage mais
aussi de recrutement dans les bassins
concernés nous le faisons et je le
précise en lien avec un autre débat qui
anime le Conseil des ministres européens
du travail qui concerne la révision de
la totalité du règlement 883 qui ne
porte pas uniquement sur le télétravail
mais bien sur l'ensemble de la
coordination de la sécurité sociale dans
les tous prochains jours sur l'autorité
de madame la Première ministre vous
arrêteront de notre position définitive
en tenant compte de l'ensemble des
paramètres mais aujourd'hui le texte
auquel nous avons participé est encore à
l'instruction de service merci la parole
est à notre collègue Jacqueline installe
Brignoud pour le groupe les républicains
merci merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
la semaine dernière sur le site
gouvernemental je veux aider.gouv.fr
plateforme publique de l'engagement on
pouvait découvrir une jeune fille voilée
qui a surépissement été remplacé trois
jours plus tard par une autre jeune
fille à la tête découverte alors ma
question est simple madame la ministre
comment nous faire croire que le
gouvernement luth contre les abayas
lorsqu'il affiche ouvertement sur un
site gouvernemental une jeune fille
voilée sous le drapeau français et donc
plus globalement quelle est la ligne du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
l'inquiétante offensive islamiste dans
notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole l'état
madame Sonia baquet secrétaire d'État
chargé de la citoyenneté madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdatrices
pas de commenter l'exemple que vous avez
pris mais nous ne sommes pas naïfs la
République l'école de la République en
particulier est en ce moment la cible
d'organisation islamiste qui vient les
réseaux sociaux organisent des attaques
contre la loi de 2004 depuis la rentrée
scolaire 2022 les services de
renseignement qui sont en lien constant
avec les responsables des communautés
éducatives
documente une tendance préoccupante sur
les atteintes à la laïcité et notamment
à l'école nous suivons cette évolution
en lien étroit avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et ses services
comme vous nous avons entendu les
demandes légitimes des enseignants et
des chefs d'établissements de disposer
de consignes claires nous leur devons
cette clarté
je me permets de vous rappeler madame la
sénatrice la loi de 2004 qui interdit
explicitement le port de tout vêtement
ostentatoire en milieu scolaire public
en application du principe de laïcité
pour le dire plus clairement et dans la
droite ligne des propos que j'avais tenu
en octobre dernier les abaya et les
Camilles constituent des vêtements
religieux par destination dès lors que
la finalité qui s'attache à leur port ne
fait aucun doute et qu'elle constitue
une tentative de contournement manifeste
de la loi de 2004 dès lors les chefs
d'établissement concernés sont fondés à
prendre des sanctions contre les élèves
à l'origine à l'origine de tels
comportements et à leur interdire
l'accès à leur établissement cette ligne
est celle du gouvernement je rappelle
qu'elle avait été indiquée dans une
instruction au préfet envoyé par Gérald
Darmanin et moi-même le 17 octobre
dernier je le dis clairement même la
sénatrice la loi de 2004 est une loi
protectrice et une loi d'émancipation et
nous devons veiller à sa stricte
application sans naïveté et sans
complaisance
rassurés et convaincus par vos propos
j'ai posé quelques questions comment
expliquer vous qu'une conférence à la
Sorbonne sur l'entrisme des Frères
musulmans initialement reportée se soit
tenu sous haute protection sans le
soutien de la ministre concerné comment
expliquer vous le silence et l'inaction
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
pour faire en sorte que le collège de
Conflans ou enseignait Samuel Paty porte
son nom comment expliquer vous
l'ambiguïté du discours gouvernemental
autour de la Baya et vous m'avez pas
rassuré fruit du wahabisme de l'islam le
plus rigoriste prenez en Arabie Saoudite
que l'on voit prospérer de manière
inquiétante dans nos collèges et nos
lycées comment expliquer vous le silence
du ministère aligalité homme-femme sur
tous ces sujets alors que de plus en
plus de petites filles sont voilées dans
notre pays petite fille auxquelles on
inculque l'idée que leur corps est sale
et impur et doit être caché du regard de
des hommes
n'y a-t-il pas des mots que tout le
monde connaît et capable de comprendre
dès son plus dès son plus jeune âge les
mots non et interdits alors pourquoi ne
jamais les utiliser afin de préserver
l'unité de la nation et de la communauté
nationale ne pas répondre à toutes ces
questions avec clarté ne pas choisir
c'est permettre l'offensive islamiste de
continuer à progresser vous en êtes et
vous en serez redevable devant les
Français
la parole est à notre collègue
Gilbert Luc de minage pour le grand
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre pôle antéflon textile
industriel emballage alimentaire les
milliers de pie face sont partout dans
notre quotidien malheureusement ces
molécules quasiment indestructibles sont
également présentes dans les rivières
l'eau de pluie les sols l'alimentation
et le lait maternel et ton face au
poison du siècle je viens de la région
la plus exposée à ces polluants éternels
après les recommandations émises par
l'ARS de ne pas consommer des poissons
pêchés dans le Rhône puis les œufs et
les volailles voilà qu'un documentaire
révèle l'imprégnation extrêmement élevée
des riverains de l'usine Arkema cette
fois plus que la moyenne des Français
une plainte a d'ailleurs été déposée le
25 mai par un collectif d'associations
et de citoyens les habitants comme les
élus sont à juste titre très inquiets
car les effets nocifs et toxiques de
certaines substances sont désormais
reconnus
selon le dernier rapport de l'Inspection
générale de l'environnement la France ne
règlemente aucun pie face le constat est
sévère pour notre pays le gouvernement a
annoncé un plan d'action pour trois ans
ou aucune norme concernant les rejets
industriels les proposer l'urgence et
pourtant réelle aussi madame la ministre
comment votre gouvernement compte t-il
accompagner les collectivités touchées
par ces problèmes qui paiera la
dépollution des sites contaminés et à
quand une vaste étude d'imprégnation sur
les populations locales
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur de Vinas mieux
prendre en compte les effets et
maîtriser les risques pour
l'environnement à la santé liée à
l'usage des péfaces les polyfluoraux
Alquines répond à une préoccupation
forte et légitime de nos concitoyens
vous l'avez dit c'est un enjeu de santé
publique essentiel et une priorité de
notre action sur laquelle le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé au
niveau national et européen sur laquelle
nous devons une transparence complète
sur les informations dont nous disposons
avec Christophe bichu nous avons
souhaité renforcer notre ambition
collective sur ce sujet dans le cadre
d'un plan d'action lanciers en gévier
dernier ce sont des actions concrètes en
matière de métairie des rejets
industriels et de connaissances des
contamination environnementales la
priorité c'est d'amélioration de la
connaissance des rejets ainsi que de
l'imprégnation des milieux pour réduire
l'exposition des populations à ce titre
l'analyse des effluents industriels
fortement susceptible de contenir des
péfaces fait actuellement l'objet d'un
projet d'arrêté ministériel ouvert à
consultation du public ce projet
d'arrêter vise environ 5000
installations industrielles sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
couvrant la quasi intégralité des sites
pouvant produire utilisés ou rejeter des
préfaces l'objectif c'est de mieux
surveiller et engager en conséquence des
actions de réduction des émissions
j'ajoute que la directive européenne eau
potable rend obligatoire à partir de
2026 le contrôle sanitaire des péfaces
dans l'eau nous avons souhaité anticiper
cette exigence et rendre ce contrôle
applicable dès janvier dernier pour
mieux surveiller la présence de ces
polluants dans les eaux concernant la
situation de Pierre Bénite en lien avec
le préfet nous avons prescrit à
l'entreprise Arkema la réduction par
palier puis l'arrêt des rejets en péface
sur le site de Pierre-Bénite d'ici fin
2024 par ailleurs à la suite de la
première campagne des mesures dans
l'environnement réalisé par Arkema
conformément aux arrêtés préfectoraux du
1er juillet 2022 des mesures
supplémentaires de préface dans les sols
et dans les végétaux ont été demandés à
l'exploitant autour de leurs
installations et à leur frais
afin d'avoir une meilleure connaissance
des risques sanitaires lancest a été
saisi en novembre dernier des éléments
de réponse sont attendus fin d'année en
complément santé publique France va
déployer le futur programme national de
biosurveillance Albane qui s'installera
s'intéressera particulièrement à cette
exposition au piface
oui merci monsieur le Président mamie
merci de votre réponse j'entends bien
surveiller c'est bien agir c'est mieux
et il me semble que si des démarches
sont lancées au niveau européen on n'est
pas obligé d'attendre la fin de ces
démarches au niveau européen je prendrai
le Danemark le Danemark interdit
certains personnes depuis 2020 il y a un
me semble-t-il au-delà de la
surveillance des mesures coercitives à
prendre merci la parole est à notre
collègue bruno Sido pour le groupe les
républicain merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre vous vantez les
mérites de l'apprentissage et vous avez
raison à ce titre vous incitez les
collectivités territoriales à recruter
plus de jeunes et à les former mais sans
moyens financiers de la part de l'État
elle ne pourront pas y parvenir en effet
depuis la loi du 6 août 2019 le Centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale et les représentants des
employeurs territoriaux cherchent un
accord de financement pérenne le nouveau
système de financement que nous avons
voté dans le blog finance pour 2022
prévoit une taxe d'apprentissage de 0,1%
pour les employeurs territoriaux en
contrepartie de quoi l'État et France
compétences financent à hauteur de 15
millions d'euros chacun et le CNFPT à
hauteur de 13 millions en début d'année
et après avoir menacé de vous retirer
sous la pression des employeurs locaux
vous allez accepter de maintenir pour
trois années supplémentaires la
contribution de l'État au frais de
formation des apprentis en collectivités
mais voilà que par une circulaire du 10
mai dernier vous uneiltéralement le
désengagement de France compétences dès
2024 passant de 15 millions en 2023 5
millions en 2025 avant extinction
complète de la participation une réelle
dynamique s'est engagée pour
l'apprentissage passant de 8000 contrats
en 2020 à 12000 en 2022 et pour 2023
on atteint les 18000 ce qui représente
un engagement financier de plus de 160
millions d'euros ce n'est pas tenable
financièrement alors même que les
recettes perçues sont de 75 millions
d'euros par le CNFPT il manque près de
87 millions d'euros dans la même
circulaire du 10 mai dernier vous
demandez aux employeurs locaux de faire
plus tout en vous désengageant alors
madame la Première ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour pérenniser le
développement de l'apprentissage dans
les collectivités
à la ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales Madame la
Ministre de la parole merci Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur sido
l'encouragement de l'apprentissage dans
les collectivités territoriales est au
cœur de nos priorités pour deux raisons
il permet aux collectivités d'attirer
des jeunes talents et il permet aux
jeunes de se confronter à une palette de
métiers au service de l'intérêt général
dans les territoires pour leur permettre
d'acquérir de solides compétences c'est
un tremplin pour l'emploi une chance
pour les collectivités cet effort passe
par un maintien de notre engagement
financier dans les collectivités
territoriales dans les années à venir à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros pour les
apprentis recrutés en 2023 en 2024 et en
2025 comme cela était précédemment prévu
pour 2022 comme vous l'avez indiqué la
première ministre a inscrit dans sa
circulaire du 10 mars 2023 relative ou
renforcement du recrutement d'apprentis
dans la fonction publique afin
d'atteindre l'objectif fixé par le
président de la République de
recrutement d'un million d'apprentis
d'ici la fin du quinquennat c'est 12000
apprentis en 2022 et probablement au
moins autant
qui rejoindront nos collectivités
locales en 2023 cet engagement de l'État
à hauteur de 45 millions d'euros sur
trois ans permettra de développer le
recrutement d'apprentis dans nos
collectivités territoriales nous sommes
d'ailleurs sur le point de finaliser la
convention qui lit l'État et le Centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale nous devons également
le cage statutaire qui empêche les
collectivités qui le souhaitent de
recruter durablement leurs apprentis
nous voulons faire de l'apprentissage
une voie de recrutement pérenne pour les
collectivités locales car nous voulons
éviter qu'elle se sépare des apprentis
au bout de deux ans c'est l'un des axes
du chantier axé parcours rémunération
menée par Stanislas Guérini ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique qui permettra de faire de
l'apprentissage une voix de pré
recrutement une réelle modalité de
recrutement dans la fonction publique
territoriale je vous remercie monsieur
mais madame la ministre vous
soufflantissage dans le privé avec de
l'argent public à hauteur de 6 milliards
d'euros par an un apprenti de public
est-il à ce point moins méritant qui ne
nécessite pas le même effort national en
termes budgétaire est-ce une énième
façon de faire peser sur les
collectivités territoriales une charge
de plus
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Daphné
rachmadou pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique vous venez d'annoncer une
augmentation du point d'indice de la
fonction publique de 1,5 % applicable au
premier juillet prochain ainsi que des
mesures complémentaires prime
facultatives ou augmentation du nombre
de points pour les agents de catégorie B
et C en 2024
dans le contexte de fortes inflation que
nous connaissons nous ne pouvons que
nous en réjouir cette augmentation
constituera un coup de pouce dont les
agents publics ont le plus grand besoin
pour soutenir leur pouvoir d'achat cette
annonce intervient cependant à une
époque de l'année où les budgets des
communes ont déjà été votés débuté déjà
contraints et avec parfois des
augmentations d'impôts décidées pour
faire face et continuer d'investir
certaines communes n'ont eu
communication de la part de leurs
fournisseurs d'énergie du montant de
leur facture d'électricité du premier
trimestre qu'après le vote de leur
budget avec parfois des augmentations
substantielles dans mon département même
avec les boucliers tarifaires elles
peuvent être de l'ordre de 40 %. en un
mot nos villes et nos villages surtout
n'ont plus une image budgétaire ni
perspective dans ces conditions on le
sait sans aide c'est l'équilibre des
budgets qui est remis en cause et va
compromettre leur investissement et leur
projet
faute de moyens d'amorce de ces projets
les collectivités ne pourront prétendre
aux aides DETR des cils fond vert ou
autre subventions les élus ont le
sentiment qu'on reprend d'un côté ce que
l'on donne de l'autre monsieur le
ministre ma question est donc simple
l'augmentation du point d'indice de la
fonction publique étant une décision
d'État l'état va-t-il compenser comme
cela a été fait même partiellement dans
la loi de finances rectificative en août
2022 enfin comme moi avez-vous et allez
vous consulter les associations d'élus
c'est celui qui sont encore et toujours
en première ligne dans nos territoires
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la transformation et de la
fonction publique monsieur Guérini merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice rakmadou vous me posez
plusieurs questions est-ce que nous
avons concerté avec les associations
d'élus la réponse est oui je les ai
réunies le 23 mai dernier je les ai
réunis à nouveau avec ma collègue
Dominique Faure le 12 juin à vendre
recevoir les syndicale et procéder à un
certain d'annonces deuxième question
c'est ce que nous avons tenu compte de
ce que nous ont dit les associations
d'élus et la réponse à nouveau c'est oui
elles nous ont dit trois choses le 23
mai 1 que l'effort indiciaire
c'est-à-dire contraint pour les
collectivités soit le plus modéré
possible 2 que nous concentrions nos
efforts sur les plus bas salaires vous
le savez la fonction publique
territoriale c'est trois quarts de
catégorie C3 que cet effort indiciaire
puisse être lissé dans le temps et
précisément les annonces que j'ai au nom
du gouvernement avec l'arbitrage la
première ministre pu porter répondre à
ces trois points l'année dernière
c'était trois et demi pour cent
d'augmentation du point d'anis en cours
d'année un et demi vous l'avez mentionné
2 nous utilisons l'enveloppe budgétaire
de façon très différente pour la
concentrer sur les plus bas salaires
c'est précisément ce que nous demandait
les associations d'élus 3 cet effort
budgétaire oui il sera lissé dans le
temps puisque une partie de l'effort
porte sur 2023 c'est l'augmentation du
point d'indice l'autre partie c'est la
distribution de points indifférencier à
toute la grille interviendra en janvier
2024 donc avec une prévisibilité plus
forte je me permets d'ajouter une
question supplémentaire peut-être la
seule qui vaille si les collectivités
avaient été seules décisionnaires que
elle soit seule en maîtrise du point
d'indice quelle décision aurait-elle
prise avec une année où nous revivons à
nouveau 6% d'inflation avec une année ou
l'inflation alimentaire est importante
quelle décision a-t-elle prise je crois
très sincèrement madame la sénatrice
qu'elle aurait pris précisément la même
décision que nous avons annoncé
avec les questions gouvernement merci
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 21 juin à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi visant
à revaloriser le métier de secrétaire de
mairie la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne parmi les
temps forts cette semaine on retiendra
ces trois questions consacrées au drame
d'Annecy la première ministre travaille
d'ailleurs redit que les petites
victimes étaient toutes hors de danger
le gouvernement qui a été interrogé sur
les leçons à tirer dans ce drame faut-il
par exemple restreindre les droits des
réfugiés à venir sur le territoire ainsi
demander un sénateur de droite la
première ministre qui s'est voulu très
prudente c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire renvoyant systématiquement à
l'enquête qui est en cours elle a dit je
refuserai toujours les tentatives de
récupération écoutez la réponse une
extrait d'une de ses réponses et le seul
moment où elle est allé véritablement
sur le thème de l'immigration écoutez
je pense en effet que ce genre de
demande d'asile et maintenant une
personne qui a déjà le statut de
réfugiés dans un autre État membre doit
pouvoir être traité plus rapidement et
nous allons également examiner ce point
au-delà des démarches importantes et des
avancées que nous portons au niveau
européen et qui ont notamment pu se
traduire lors du dernier conseil des
ministres de l'intérieur par la
définition d'une procédure de demande
d'asile obligatoire aux frontières de
l'Europe qui je pense répond à notre
attente et répond à l'attente de
beaucoup des timbres européens c'est
étonnant lors de cette séance les
écologistes on salué la réponse
politique de la première ministre depuis
jeudi dernier alors que les vautours
avec quitté leur nid plus vite qu'à la
coutumée vous avez appelé à la dignité a
dit ainsi le chef de fil des sénateurs
écologistes écoutez la suite
alors que les vautours avaient quitté
leur nid plus vite qu'à le coutumé vous
avez avec la droiture que vous nous
connaissons appelé chacun à la dignité
nous saluons ce propos nous le faisons
notre
des compliments qui ont fait sourire la
première ministre qui est pas assis
attendre et qui est pas habitué à ce
genre de compliments de la part des
écologistes du Sénat un dernier mot pour
vous dire Tam que la première ministre a
été très présente lors de cette séance
des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement avec les quatre réponses
sur et bien les 16 questions peut-être
aussi Tam et bien pour occuper l'espace
dans le contexte de rumeurs d'un
remaniement ministériel merci merci
beaucoup Quentin pour ce décryptage il y
a aussi quelques questions de présidents
de groupe mais c'est vrai que cela
faisait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
autant entendu Elisabeth Bank
s'exprimait dans l'hémicycle on continue
le débrief de ces questions gouvernement
et on rejoint salle des conférences
Alexandre qui se trouve avec le
président du groupe LR au Sénat Bruno
Retailleau effectivement effectivement
bonjour Bruno Retailleau bonjour à vous
alors cet après-midi le gouvernement a
confirmé qu'il allait présenter en
conseil des ministres la dissolution de
l'association de militants écologistes
soulèvement de la terre c'est une bonne
décision selon vous c'est une bonne
décision parce que ce qui s'est passé il
y a quelques jours à Nantes contre des
maraîchers qui précisément cultivaient
des plantes qui seraient plus
résistantes demain pour le changement
climatique ça c'est la recherche c'est
géni humain qui va nous permettre
d'ailleurs de trouver des solutions
contre ce réchauffement climatique on a
affaire des délinquants et il y avait
des élus encore une fois avec les
chartes tricolores mais voyez il y a
quelque chose de très symbolique puisque
nous étions à Nantes tout près de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes soulèvement de la
terre est né justement à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et c'est parce que
je pense que Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État alors avait en réalité donné un
vrai permis à ces ultra violents un
permis de casser un parmi d'occuper des
terres qui n'étaient pas les leurs que
cette spirale s'est enchaînée et je
pense que là il y a une vraie
responsabilité mais évidemment
soulèvement de la terre qui se à chaque
fois en marge de la loi doivent être
dissous alors ce matin la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur l'affaire du fond
Marianne à auditionner la ministre
Marlène Schiappa sur eh bien sa
responsabilité dans les éditionnements
de la mise en place de ce fond qui était
censé lutter contre la radicalisation et
finalement Marlène chappa est bien elle
s'est un petit peu défaussée de ses
responsabilités vis-à-vis de son cabinet
de son administration ça vous semble
crédible et c'est des fossés quand
c'était pas sa faute c'était celle de
son administration quand c'était pas
celle de l'administration c'était celle
de son cabinet il y a juste une
contradiction comment peut-elle
expliquer qu'elle est soit intervenue
personnellement pour priver SOS Racisme
de toute subventions alors que par
ailleurs elle dit qu'elle s'est occupée
de rien il y a la manifestation et
manifestement un problème une
contradiction qu'elle donnera levée un
moment ou un autre elle peut rester en
poste au gouvernement selon vous moi
j'ai pas l'habitude de demander les
démissions des ministres pour une bonne
et simple raison c'est que la décision
de m'appartient pas tant que j'entends
systématiquement toutes les semaines des
professionnels qui demandent des
démissions des ministres en tout cas
c'est à elle de voir et c'est à nous en
tout cas d'éclairer d'éclaircir les
choses qui n'ont pas été transparentes
alors même je vous rappelle les
conditions dans lesquelles c'est créer
ce font c'est juste après la
décapitation de effectivement dans des
circonstances dramatiques alors on va
parler de l'avenir du gouvernement il y
a effectivement des rumeurs de
remaniement on a vu Elisabeth borne très
actif cet après-midi dans cette séance
de questions d'actualité est-ce que
selon vous le gouvernement borne à
l'avenir je ne le sais pas je vous
répondrai la même chose que je vous ai
répondu sur les démissions voilà c'est
Jupiter qui va en décider c'est pas
Bruno Retailleau simplement ce que je
veux dire c'est que elle ou quelqu'un
d'autre qu'est-ce que ça changerait on
s'est parfaitement que celui qui tire
les fils de la politique française et
notamment du gouvernement c'est Emmanuel
Macron donc si c'est simplement pour
changer des têtes pour un problème de
casting ça ne fera rien de plus ce qui
changeait peut-être la donne c'est une
alliance entre la majorité
présidentielle et les républicains alors
que le parti de la majorité Renaissance
va travailler justement sur cette
alliance avec les LR elle est encore
possible est-ce que est-ce que ce n'est
pas la seule solution
mais les conditions sont pas réunies
d'abord parce que ce genre d'alliance
doit se faire dans la transparence
certainement pas dans la combinaison de
couloirs loin du peuple ça doit se faire
dans l'isoloir dans les conditions de
transparence vis-à-vis notamment de nos
électeurs ils ont et lui ils ont élu nos
députés pour siéger dans l'opposition et
un autre problème je parlais tout à
l'heure de Notre-Dame-des-Landes avec
lequel email Macron ferait-on un accord
avec celui qui a autorisé en réalité
notre âme des land enfin les
destructeurs de notre âme des Landes
aller plus avant c'est-à-dire les
hadistes ou ce celui le mal Macron qui
combat les mêmes zadistes à Sainte
solide il y a un vrai problème de ligne
et pour nous le en même temps est un
vrai souci parce que c'est l'incohérence
donc il faudra changer de ligne pour
permettre cette alliance merci beaucoup
Bruno Retailleau d'être venu au micro de
Public Sénat
merci merci beaucoup Alexandre à penser
réactions à la suite des questions au
gouvernement et on enchaîne les
réactions à votre micro avec d'autres
présidents de groupe puisque vous avez
François Patriat le président du groupe
du sénateur Renaissance à votre micro
effectivement François Patriat d'abord
une réaction sur ce qui a annoncé le
gouvernement cette après-midi il
confirme qu'il va présenter en conseil
des ministres la dissolution de
l'association les soulèvements de la
terre c'est une décision nécessaire je
pense que c'est une décision sage je
pense qu'elle est attendue quand on voit
de telles associations se conduire de la
façon dont ils se conduisent d'aller
soutenir les extrêmes et se confronter
aux forces de l'ordre d'avoir à pouvoir
j'allais dire de nuisances pour la
aujourd'hui tels que le conduit
aujourd'hui moi je pense que cette
décision je la plaie de mes vœux qu'elle
est nécessaire oui vous parleriez des
coups terroristes comme l'a fait votre
collègue de la républicain Laurence
Garnier
elle a de neige je crois qu'elle a j'ai
pas vu là ce matin à l'audition j'étais
en commission des affaires étrangères
mais là je peux m'a dit elle a avec
beaucoup d'humilité dit voilà que
comment comment elle avait géré les
choses comment elle avait défendu ce
dossier
elle a répondu aux questions au fond les
questions sur lesquelles elle n'est pas
de réponse immédiate elle a pas répondu
je ne vois pas des choses vraiment je ne
vois pas dans ce qu'on lui reproche
aujourd'hui des choses très importantes
qui mènerait très loin voilà donc pour
vous il y a pas de problème Marlène
chapelle dans cette affaire je pense que
aujourd'hui il y a la première ministre
a dit elle-même je moi je souhaite à
titre personnel parce que parce que
c'est une amie parce qu'elle travaille
parce qu'elle est une bonne ministre je
souhaite qu'elle reste au gouvernement
ou alors concernant l'avenir de ce
gouvernement est-ce qu'ils font un
remaniement pour lui donner un nouveau
souffle un nouveau cap politique
j'entends bien ces temps pressements et
cette agitation autour j'entends bien
néanmoins je regarde les choses ce
gouvernement a une s'est fixé une
feuille de route de 100 jours dans
laquelle il a fait la démonstration que
le gouvernement travaille que les
assemblées aujourd'hui aboutissent à des
accords il n'y a pas eu de phase 3 sur
beaucoup de textes aujourd'hui il y en a
le gouvernement va faire passer dans ces
100 jours la loi sur l'industrie verte
la loi de programmation militaire la loi
travail la loi justice en ayant trouvé à
chaque fois des accords donc quand on
remplit il y a pas beaucoup de
gouvernement qui en trois mois auront
fait voter des textes autant
d'importance le temps de coupe par
ailleurs donc ça faut aller aujourd'hui
on dire le gouvernement doit y avoir un
remaniement moi je ne pense pas
aujourd'hui qu'il a besoin d'un minimum
dans l'immédiat est-ce que ce serait à
la hauteur de l'événement je ne pense
pas du tout et je crois que il faut
laisser le gouvernement travailler il y
a d'autres projets de texte pour
l'automne il y a le texte de loi sur la
fin de vie il y a le texte de loi sur
l'immigration il y a le budget à voter
c'est le gouvernement est au travail je
ne suis pas de ceux qui appellent
fébrilement systématiquement à renverser
le gouvernement est-ce que selon vous il
y a besoin d'une alliance avec les
républicains alors que le parti
Renaissance va travailler sur cette
question que répondez-vous à Bruno
Retailleau qui est à l'instant disait
pour qu'il y alliance il faut d'abord
qu'Emmanuel Macron change de ligne et
clarifie sa ligne
moi je ne crois pas à l'alliance
vraiment à du franchement je ne pense
pas que hier chez les républicains
autant de discours qu'il y a de
responsable alors trouve une alliance
avec un parti dans lequel il y a autant
de discours discordants on l'a vu sur
tous les sujets aujourd'hui ça me paraît
difficile moi je crois aujourd'hui
plutôt au texte par texte tel que les
conduits aujourd'hui et si on doit
trouver si on doit élargir la majorité
il faut élargir à droite et à gauche
demain je pense que pour faire face à
l'extrême droite il faudra un grand bloc
central qui réunissent des gens de
gauche et des gens de droite pour être
vraiment crédible pour pouvoir préformer
merci beaucoup François Patriat pour
votre réaction c'est à vous merci merci
on va faire le débrief de ces questions
au Gouvernement sur ce plateau et pour
cela j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir Martin
de cidrac bonjour c'est une actrice les
républicains des Yvelines et face à vous
Sébastien plat bonjour c'est Nathan
socialiste de l'Aude alors on a dit que
Elisabeth borne en tout cas pouvait être
menacé par un potentiel remaniement mais
elle a été très présente lors de cette
séance de questions au Gouvernement elle
a été interpellée à de nombreuses
reprises et notamment par le président
du groupe écologiste Guillaume Gontard
qui a interrogé la première ministre
après le drame d'Annecy je vous propose
de revenir sur cet enfant de la séance
public aujourd'hui quoi moi je suis
scandalisé de voir des agissements de
voir des mouvements politiques qui
appellent sans arrêt sans arrêt aller
sur action au tribunal populaire nous
vivons dans une république notre
République est magnifique elle permet à
tout le monde de s'épanouir elle nous
soigne et nos enfants cette situation de
rattrapage moi pour moi il peut vraiment
un scandaleuse et je voulais vraiment
souligner l'intervention de Guillaume
Gontard qui est une intervention du
niveau de celle que nous avons au Sénat
avec beaucoup d'élévation vis-à-vis de
la première à l'unité et qui une fois
n'est pas coutume a aussi rendu hommage
à la réaction de la première guerre
ministre que je salue pour son courage
face à cette situation que je soutiens
car il faut le dire à Françoise Tangle
mère de d'Annecy écologiste porte
plainte il a fait l'objet de menaces
racistes de messages haineux après et
bien c'est terrible drame d'Annecy et
notamment parce que il avait d'abord dit
que Annecy était d'une terre d'accueil
plusieurs jours un bien avant ce drame
et que c'était une ville qui était
ouverte pour accueillir les réfugiés ça
vous choque aussi à Martha Sidrac bien
sûr tout violence me choque quelle
qu'elle soit et d'où qu'elle vienne pour
cela je pense que nous ne pouvons
qu'être tous d'accord et je crois que si
on veut être dans un une république de
droit aucun d'entre nous ne pourrait
dire que ce qui s'est passé soit tout à
fait acceptable en revanche je pense
qu'il ne faut pas que nous oublions le
fond de ce drame et ce que cela révèle y
compris auprès de nos concitoyens les
Français qui vivent ces drames là vous
avez évoqué chers collègues ce qu'on a
vécu à Saint-Brévin bien sûr donc la
récupération politique elle a toujours
existé il existera toujours qu'elle soit
de gauche ou qu'elle soit de droite donc
les extrêmes aujourd'hui dans des deux
côtés de l'échiquier l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite ne se prive pas de
faire de la récupération en revanche
nous je dirais qui sommes attachés à une
république forte il faut que nous soyons
très attentifs
que cela révèle parce que ça révèle pour
vous le fond du problème c'est que vous
voyez et c'est le vrai sujet qui va se
poser à nous tous que faisons-nous en
fait de la libre circulation dans
l'espace européen c'est une vraie
question que l'on doit se poser sans
aucun a priori il ne s'agit pas de dire
un tel a raison un tel a tort mais c'est
une véritable question et c'est une
véritable préoccupation pour nos
concitoyens et ça il faut qu'on y
réponde alors est-ce que ça pose au
niveau européen la question des règles
de circulation qui doivent être associés
aux droits d'asile pour les réfugiés
puisque c'était le cas pour la saillant
Nancy ça va faire l'objet j'imagine
d'une loi probablement à la rentrée sur
ses
[Musique]
jugement à porter sur ces sujets là
n'étant pas un spécialiste de ces
questions là cela dit encadrer la libre
circulation est une chose importante
mais cependant malheureusement c'est à
déploré que cette situation aujourd'hui
nous amène au pire
stigmatisme beaucoup ce genre de de
phénomène mais on parle moins de
féminicine féminicides il y en a tous
les 48 heures donc voilà il faut aussi
aborder les sujets avec l'ajuste
proportion et j'ai l'impression que les
questions migratoires des chaînes n'est
pas passions je suis d'accord avec vous
à Bordeaux les sujets de manière
consensuelle avec du recul surtout par
rapport au phénomène ce drame pose la
question de l'immigration pour vous en
l'occurrence elle doit ouvrir elle doit
questionner sur la question de
l'immigration moi
de la ville justement pour pour
m'imprégner de la situation des immigrés
oui ça nécessite un travail clair on en
parle mais on a fait combien de loi
immigration depuis 30 ans
on a toujours des problèmes il y a
toujours de la polémique est-ce que
nécessairement passer par la loi c'est
ça la question aussi pas sûr pas certain
une nouvelle loi immigration évidemment
et sur le métier moi je crois que avant
d'aller loi pas loin on l'aura on aura
le débat et moi je me réjouis je pense
qu'il faut se poser la question
véritablement de la volonté politique
que l'on a aujourd'hui dans ce pays pour
pouvoir résoudre des problèmes qui se
posent de plus en plus au quotidien
c'est une réalité et je pense je ne suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec les propos
qui vient d'être dit en totalité
notamment opposer une cause par rapport
à une autre cause ce n'est pas parce que
nous avons énormément de féminicides et
je suis d'accord avec vous je ne peux
qu'être d'accord c'est un sujet
éminemment prégnant aujourd'hui dans
notre société que pour autant il faille
oublier que nous avons aussi d'autres
sujets tout aussi prégnants et tout
aussi importants pour le quotidien de
l'ensemble de des Français donc je crois
que il ne faut pas opposer il ne faut
pas qu'on se disperse il faut que l'on
soit tout ferme sur tous ces différents
sujets et ce n'est pas parce que on va
les traiter avec fermeté dans les deux
cas il peut y avoir d'autres sujets
aussi que pour autant cela nous rendra
plus faible moi donc moi personnellement
je pense et je suis contente que nous
puissions j'espère j'espère vraiment
avoir un vrai débat sur l'immigration
qui est aujourd'hui éminemment prégnante
dans notre société malheureusement j'ai
envie de dire un autre sujet qui est
posé par et bien ce drame d'Annecy c'est
l'état de la psychiatrie catastrophique
c'est ce qui a soulevé votre collègue
Loïc Hervé ça aussi c'est un sujet en
rappelant que au départ dès que la
nationalité de la série a été connu on
est beaucoup de personnalités de
l'extrême droite vous allez directement
voilà sur la question islamiste ça n'est
pas du tout le cas la question qui se
pose aussi celle de la psychiatrie
aujourd'hui oui mais la psychiatrie en
réalité
imprègne l'ensemble de notre société
vous savez rappelez-vous les questions
que l'on se posait à l'issue du covid
notamment pour nos jeunes nos jeunes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas suffisamment
accompagnés sur ces sujets là donc je
crois que la psychiatrie est un sujet
très vaste qui concerne la santé
publique en réalité dans notre pays on
va pas lancer le débat là-dessus qui est
un vaste débat également sur l'état de
notre santé aujourd'hui mais oui bien
sûr la psychiatrie est un sujet sur
lequel il va falloir que l'on se penche
on manque pas de problème de sujet on ne
manque pas de problème à l'échopper on
ne manque pas de sujet d'ailleurs
c'était l'angle de la question posée par
le sénateur Loïc Hervé lorsqu'il a
interpellé le gouvernement tout à
l'heure on l'écoute premièrement si le
fonctionnement de l'espace Schengen fixe
des règles européennes de liberté de
circulation il n'existe pas en soi de
liberté d'établissement l'auteur des
faits semblerait avoir choisi de résider
dans les rues d'Annecy depuis 7 mois
deuxièmement l'état de la psychiatrie
hospitalière en Haute-Savoie et
catastrophique des services ont été
fermés à l'hôpital de Thonon pour être
transféré à l'hôpital de La
Roche-sur-Foron ou un tiers des lits
enfermé par manque de personnel dans ces
conditions comment imaginer une
politique de prévention digne de ce nom
comment aller vers les populations de
102000 ficile fixe souvent étrangers de
plus en plus nombreux qui sont dans des
situations de véritable marginalité la
question qui se pose c'est donc aussi la
question de l'état de notre système de
santé Sébastien plat ah oui profondément
c'est clair bon je sais pas on va pas
réouvrir le sujet de la santé mais c'est
un angle mort extraordinaire questionne
de la psychiatrie au niveau de la santé
mais cela dit le cas d'espèce une
personne qui est pas intérêt dans la
société pas forcément suivi non plus
donc se poser la question justement des
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui à la rue
c'est le cas de dire et qui ne sont pas
suivis du tout par les systèmes de
système socio et système de santé alors
notre sujet qui a marqué cette séance de
questions au gouvernement et bien c'est
la question qui a été posée par votre
compte
garanti a demandé réclamer à nouveau et
bien la dissolution du de l'association
les soulèvements de la terre et cela
après des événements qui sont intervenus
près de Nantes écoutez et bien son
échange avec Olivier Véran tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle sur le site et
c'est encore plus grave
il y avait des élus de la République
présent en écharpe tricolore aux côtés
de céderlinquants ils sont la honte de
notre République à Saint-Brévin il
défilait la main sur le cœur contre les
violences d'extrême droite le 11 juin à
Pont-Saint-Martin il soutenait les
violences des écho théoriques d'extrême
gauche il y a quelque chose qui ne va
pas clairement il y a quelque chose qui
ne va pas un élu de la République quel
que soit son mandat quel que soit son
parti n'a pas à participer à une
manifestation lorsqu'elle est interdite
par la préfecture c'est la base c'est la
base
un élu de la République n'a
pas apparence et donc à cautionner par
sa présence des exactions qui sont
réalisées en l'occurrence contre des
agriculteurs